we've already had several videos where
we give an overview of the crusades and
just as a review they happen over
roughly 200 years during the high middle
ages the first crusade at the very end
of the 11th century and actually the
most successful of the crusades allowing
the western european powers to take
control of jerusalem and much of the
holy land and you could see that here on
this diagram where jerusalem at least
goes from green to red controlled by the
western european the latin christians
and they're able to maintain control
through these crusader kingdoms all the
way until 1187 when salah adin is able
to retake control of jerusalem
then a few decades later as we go into
the sixth crusade and the barons crusade
which isn't depicted here the western
europeans are able to take more control
but eventually the muslims take control
of jerusalem and as we enter into the
14th century they have control of the
entire holy land now while that is
happening constantinople gets sacked at
the end of the fourth crusade by the
crusaders themselves and even though
it's retaken this is really the
beginning of the end for the byzantine
empire so let's think a little bit about
how the crusades changed europe and the
entire world well one of the obvious
impacts of the crusades was just the
amount of death it caused it's estimated
that the death toll from the crusades is
two to six million people just from
western europe and just to put that into
perspective the european population at
the time was about 60 to 70 million
folks so we're talking about 4 to 10
percent of the population dying in the
crusades and this isn't fully accounting
for all of the death and destruction
that happened on the way to the crusades
or that happened in the middle east as
well
if you look at this map of what the
region looks like as we get into the
14th century right over here you can see
that although the middle east is still
in control of the muslims muslims have
for the most part been pushed out of the
iberian peninsula and they have a little
bit of a foothold right here in granada
and this reconquista is going to
continue all the way until 1492
when what will be the spanish are able
to push out all of the muslims from the
iberian peninsula and as they do that
they also expel the jews you also have
territorial gains in the north of europe
that's a little bit harder to see on
this map over here as i mentioned in
previous video part of this crusader
mentality was not just about taking land
back for the byzantines or taking land
from the muslims but also trying to take
land or convert what were perceived as
pagans in the north german tribes that
had not as yet converted to christianity
and so that helped for territorial
expansion in the north of europe
now a big theme in the crusades was the
power
of the pope remember the crusades were
started by a pope working people up
saying hey let's go help the byzantines
let's go take back land from the muslims
pope urban ii and over the course of
this 200 years you have this religious
fervor where the pope is organizing
these crusades people are feeling this
religious spirit
many people are before going on their
crusade they're bequeathing their land
to the church if they die and many of
these lords do end up dying they're
giving their property to the church
headed by the pope
kings also gained power during the
crusades in other videos we talk about
the feudal system and many times the
vassals to the kings the dukes the
counts the barons often had more control
over their territory than the kings
might have had and they were constantly
squabbling with each other but as people
started to focus their energies on this
external adventure known as the crusades
first of all many of these lords died
their property went back to the state
went back to the kings you have you
start having less internal dissension in
a way this idea that pope urban ii
thought of at the end of the 11th
century hey why don't i point people
externally so they stop worrying about
what's going on internally it kind of
worked
another trend is the importance of
cities in the feudal system it's all
about these manners and all about these
estates but in order to finance the
crusades centers of trade and commerce
became more important and also as there
was more interaction between west and
east and more people traveling you can
imagine that it fostered trade which
centered at these cities and that goes
into the next point commerce and trade
itself was fostered by the crusades it
wasn't all fighting the venetians and
other trader city-states they helped
facilitate the movement of arms and
people from west to east but on the way
back they also brought goods to trade
and so they became much much more
powerful in fact by the end of the
crusades as we get into the 14th century
venice which is right over here on our
map was considered the richest and most
powerful city in europe
venice has all of this trader wealth and
it's not just from trade as you might
remember from previous videos when
constantinople was sacked it was sacked
in part by these venetian traders and
after that they built an empire they
broke up the byzantine empire and took
some of it for themselves
and so it's not a coincidence that as we
get into the 14th and 15th centuries
places like venice and florence famously
sponsored by the medici family a famous
banking family so once again these are
centers of trade centers of commerce
became the places
where the renaissance would first
flourish and last but not least as in
some ways bloody and dark a time as the
crusades were they were also associated
with learning because you had all of
these people go from western europe to
the middle east and the holy land and at
that time remember we have videos on the
golden age of islam in a lot of ways
they were shepherding the knowledge of
the ancient greeks and the romans and
they were merging that with knowledge
from the indians and the chinese and
also coming up with innovations on their
own and a lot of the western europeans
brought that back to europe